-So now I thought I'd shar
some my favorite
"Add a Word, Ruin a Book"
responses from you guys.
This first one's from
@haleyvictory.
She says,
"Charlotte's Web History."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-See how it works?
-[ Laughs ]
-This is next one's
from @KerinOn.
She says "The Conference Cal
of the Wild."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
"Who's on?"
Buck.
-Buck.
This one's from @Carlstawicki.
-Oh.
-Carl Stawicki.
Wicky, wicky, wicky,
wicky, wicky -- shut up.
-Oh. I was too late.
[ Laughter ]
My name is Chilly B.
Uh, he --
Oh, this one, @Carlstawicki.
He says, "Charlie Manson
and the Chocolate Factory.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, man!
It's all in here, man."
[ Laughter ]
"Everlasting gobstopper, man."
-"Had it all along man."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @gumgummerson.
-Oh.
-He says, "Jane Eyre Pods.
[ Laughter ]
That's my favorite one, yeah
"He is the left pod
to my right...pod."
This next one's
from @meganstotts1.
She says, "This is Baby Yoda."
Oh, that's my --
That's my jam.
That's my book.
-Aww.
-Let's see that graphic again.
I should do that.
I like that one.
-Baby Yoda, come on.
-Thank you @meganstotts1.
This one is from @Jackyboy2232
He says,
"Yertle the Turtle Soup."
Oh, hey.
Come on, now.
These are jokes.
This one's from @beingnatebrown.
He says
"Fifty Shades of Grey Poupon."
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-Classy.
That's very classy.
-That's very good.
Last one's from @shelleylerma.
She says,
"Jurassic Trailer Park."
There you have it, everybody
-Oh!
Those are our hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.